but it was close I get to her and I'm
more confident once I'm in the ring I'm
a god no one could beat me a good fight
just to be diligent and committed and
discipline doing what you hate to do but
do it like you love it and I've done
have a passion in love and it's doing it
for money it's dumb the emotional
outcomes will be disastrous
not necessarily decide that the guys
know me is debated the spirit and a
competitive in his heart as we get older
we lose our hair we lose that key if we
lose my mother's talent I don't believe
in town many times I quit boxing before
I became a professional boxer he's an
American former professional boxer he
was known for his ferocious and
intimidating boxing style as well as his
controversial behavior inside and
outside the ring nicknamed iron or Kid
Dynamite he's considered to be one of
the greatest heavyweight boxers of all
time he's Mike Tyson and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success number
10 is my personal favorite some curious
to find out which one you guys like the
most and make sure to stick around all
the way to the end for some special
bonuses while I'm in the dressing room
five minutes before I come out my gloves
are laced up I'm breaking my gloves down
and broke I'm pushing the lever on the
back of my neck in the middle of the
glove form I know could pierce due to
like I feel my knuckle piercing against
a tight leather gloves on me Everlast
boxing when I come out I have supreme
confidence I'm scared to death I'm
totally afraid I'm afraid of everything
I'm afraid of losing I'm afraid of being
a milli eight but I was totally
confident plus I get to ring more
confidence I get closer more confidence
I get the closer more confident or
during my training I've been afraid of
this man I thought this man might be
capable to beat me I've dreamed of him
being me but I hope I always stayed
afraid of him but it was close I get to
her and I'm more confident once I'm in
the ring I'm a god no one could beat me
I'm walking around the ring but I never
I never take my eyes off my opponent I
keep my eyes on even the fees we're
ready and pumping he can't wait to get
his hands on me as well I keep my eyes
on my keep my hands on him I keep my
eyes on them once I see a [ __ ] in his
armor boom and one of his eyes may move
and then I know I have them then when it
comes to the center of the Ring he still
looks at me with his piercing looking
that if he's not afraid but he already
made that mistake when when he looked
down for that one tenth of a second I
know I had a fight hard for the first
two or three round I know I already
broke his spirit during the fight I'm
supremely confident I'm moving my head
he throwing punches I'm making the mess
and I'm countering I'm hitting them to
the body I'm pushing real hard and I'm
punching and punching and I know he's
not able to take my budget one-two-three
punch I'm throwing them punches and
lunches he goes down he's out I'm
victorious Mike Tyson greatest fighter
ever lived a good fighter is not
necessarily the greatest fighter that
lives what way you want to go you know I
mean a good fighter just to be diligent
and committed and discipline doing what
you hate to do but do it like you love
it you know always testing yourself
forcing yourself to the limits you know
if you know you um like if you love
women then deny yourself that you know I
mean that's what that's what I'm
successful generals all about sacrifice
for my experience of any little success
I may have had its be willing to
sacrifice you know unfortunately
sometimes you can't have fun
accomplishing their goals and when
sometimes people arm don't have the
determination the well and the
steadfastness the tenacity they are they
giving them the slightest struggle I
wouldn't do anything less I'm passionate
about it you know okay anymore that's
where I learned about peace and
happiness there
the passion and love and your student
for money it's the emotional outcomes
will be disastrous and that's for my
expense this is really well know so I
know has to be up it's for pure passion
and the love for what I'm doing as a
smaller boxer yourself in terms of
stature
how do you take on these big guys with a
big reach I don't know it's not
necessarily the size of the guy you know
mr. basically the spirit and the
competitive in his heart you know the
guy wants to fight it'll be four foot
two and fighter guys six foot nine you
know when you won the fight you're gonna
fight me and do well that's just the
average of law here in the game of
boxing you really want to do it you're
gonna do well but what I found out in
life as life goes on life is about
losing as we get older we lose our hair
we lose our teeth we lose mothers
fathers or sisters and um but it's the
ones who overcome they're lost in life
and shun away adversity and always
willing to fight it every particular
moment in life are the ones that are
able to transcend and be able to spread
the world to other people who's in that
same particular gender as they are in
order to be great you know I mean you
have prepared to fail greatly as well
you know it's all about how you handle
the failures you know and I'm I'm good
at handling failures yeah
and I'm gonna have I don't know I'm
playing that's a good hand let's accept
I can handle failure bet I gather I feel
I was born to fight because I have no
other interest in anything else anybody
is a fighter in their own right you're a
fighter I'm a fighter everyone that's in
this room even a newspaperman a fighter
but everybody don't get up every morning
and run everybody don't go to the gym
every morning
anybody don't have enough discipline to
wait in the locker room for two hours or
three hours then going the ring and do
what they've been taught all those years
in the gym and so that's what separates
a champion I'm a mediocre fighter talent
I don't believe in town
well some people they have town that's
it's good it helps when you have talent
long as you have a lot of determination
and willpower that's all you need you
have to have the will to win all know
about your love for custom ATO how much
of him is in you when you're doing this
I don't know I'm just not him maybe I'm
[ __ ] to do this for another 20 years
or so I may I may be somewhere in there
close to his level of protection of his
fighters above Adam now enormous it's
not that I miss now this season
experiences that mr. D'Amato was you
speak of him in the present tense he's
very much with you at all times
pretty much yeah very much would you
have him is one of the most special
people in your life
absolutely no one could inspire me as
much as he you know if I was
discouraging I think you know because
sometimes I'm sure in your field he said
what really things may got difficult
something may happen in your life I
don't want to do this no more we all go
through that I don't want to do this no
more and he would inspire me if they
hate this is the route to go he would
inspire me to wanna do many times I quit
boxing before I became a professional
boxer
an average I quit I didn't want to do it
and um he gave me the desperation or
even but why I should be doing this my
old job was yesterday
inflict pain and people mind like the
intimidation factor yeah that's the
biggest aspect of anything in life is
intimidation because once the person was
a great anything is in timid it can no
longer perform under the high level that
is normally accustomed to working
because he's intimidated he shut down
yeah and I'm the madness and I'm the
master then I put it up a little bit the
most intimidating athlete in the history
of the world of sports forget that the
good boxer history of the world of
sports and you have to be willing boxing
or sports than everything and life is
all about a bluff it's almost like
playing cards like I say more soaked and
um I think more so than I think she'll
indict yeah you know because you could
change dices and stuff but they can't
they're hard they can't mold and I mean
you guys gotta keep just shooting me the
shoe cards could Bend
yeah cause have been like right [ __ ]
life we can bend and even though we got
a bad hand don't we lose the game right
you know make a ghost and then we're
gonna hold it to the end and it's the
same way in fighting yeah and then life
because we were born as swallows and the
sewers and gutters that don't mean we're
gonna stay there if we have to desire
willpower
perseverance to be able to
and doing the pain yeah nothing do that
pain you know look at me everybody likes
me now yeah the last man standing
anybody likes the last minute what will
people remember about Mike Tyson 50
years from now 50 years I'm not a most
destructive for oh she's fighting
machine the god alloh created yeah
that's what I think
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Ali Hassan asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Mike
Tyson's top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you and why leave it in the
comments I will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon
took a long time to grow up then it took
a long time to grow up and gather with
responsibilities of life you know you're
boxing playing brothers being football
on us at what we do you're living living
the life of Riley even unlike the kid
you'll have many responsibilities
what you miss most about the lesson oh
the old days it's not much I miss about
it no because when you really think
about it the height of my career I'm
making them 3040 million a fight doing
what I want anybody want to see me I see
what television
stranor feet of my life and I make a
phone call I mean anybody do what I want
to do but I didn't have any peace you
know I didn't have peace and now I'm at
the I'm living at the height of my
career I don't make a tenth of the money
that I made them and I got cartoons I've
show I could have never accomplished
this and I was fighting I wouldn't never
got along with the buhdeuce out of an
arrogant I was just you learned
humbleness soon as you get old their
life and you learn um if you don't come
in this world humble if there's a world
with trust humbleness upon you do you
think it's more important to be
respected or feared I would like to be
respected respected it's more powerful
in love I believe you know but how many
people are the obligation of love
Makaveli had an obligation of love have
we heard just think about everybody
that's listen do you think I'd an
obligation of love this is my sister my
brother my girlfriend that is cheating
on my boyfriend who I didn't tell her
everything else he shoulda knew this is
not his child whatever the situation may
be you know I mean we just have to know
um this is what it is
and I mean some people can get by with
just being respected some people could
hire us for being feared the Mitch blood
green story is the greatest story ever
told
I've we hope Mitch is still around yeah
I love that story the best in your
one-man show you talk about like you
like this guy might even show up but
like he actually has you worried at one
point because because every time I'm
somewhere this guys popping up you know
I'm in a hospital because of McCarthy
he's I think this might look outside I
look at my hospital window it's a crowd
and if the present he's given the end of
you called me I've had enough sitting
there typing home on Mike Tyson
holy for those of you that don't know
the Mitch blood green story he fought
Mitch blood green and he beat him then
he like terrorized Mike for years would
show up its Horrors at restaurants and
would try to fight him all the time so
Mike's getting fitted for a suit one
night then there's this place what was
it and Dan Harlem to Harlem all right in
Harlem where yeah we buy them you know
knockoff stuff right and he said this
place would it was a place where you
would go get fitted for suits and it was
open at 3:00 4:00 in the morning and he
said that might sound weird to you but
pimps rappers and everybody else would
go get suited at this place so that's
why it was open that late and he said
Mitch blood green came walking in one
day and started you know calling him all
kinds of names and they and he said he
was like a zombie he said he hit him and
he broke his hand when he hit him and he
knock about he knocked him out dead and
then he gets up like Jason and like no
buh-buh-buh-buh
my right hand is gone my children like
he's Oh walk make me you know don't
throw the dog she keep locking this guy
out and the guy keeps getting up and
chasing after him out of the thing then
and then the game changer is he rips the
mirror off Mike Tyson's Rolls Royce and
mike has to get out knock him out again
before he drives away I think my little
boys boys to break the window off Biggs
little mirror the side mirror right
yeah burped it off